seven segment displays are great we
don't see them as much in electronics
these days because screens are a lot
cheaper than they used to be but
these used to be everywhere from clocks
to supermarket checkouts to calculators
to slot machines
here they're being used as part of the
mega processor at the center for
computing history in cambridge
this is the clock speed that the whole
system is running at
seven segment displays are a really
clever bit of design
seven is the minimum number of segments
required to show every number
using straight lines it doesn't matter
that the four
isn't actually how most people write a
number four it's close enough that we've
all just got used to it
and seven segments plus a decimal point
means that there are eight
lights here to turn on or off which is
convenient computers
like working with eights there are eight
bits in a byte so you can store the
state of those lights in just
one byte of memory and you can use these
for some letters
too you could show the word error or
even base 16 numbers but
there's no way you can write an m or a w
on this display so
here is a code question for you what is
the longest english word
that you can write on a seven segment
display
[Music]
i love questions like this because there
are so many ways to approach them
i'm going to give one solution here
because that's the way i want to tell
the story
but i can think of a couple of others
just off the top of my head and there
will be
a dozen more that i haven't thought of
or maybe couldn't even think of
to start off we need a dictionary
unfortunately here the work has been
done for us
there is a public domain list of english
words available i'll put the link in the
description
now this is not a perfect list right at
the top there are two different
spellings of ah
and i'm really not sure either of those
should count but
the list is good enough for our purposes
we can manually filter it later if there
are any strange results
now i'm going to code this in javascript
using node not the best language but
it's not bad for beginners and
importantly it's easy for me to explain
first we're going to add a bit of
boilerplate code just stock stuff to get
it working
did i know all that code off by heart no
of course not i googled load array from
file in node and i adapted some of the
results
this is basically how everyone codes
stuff like that don't ever be afraid
that you're not a real programmer
because you still look stuff up
the important part about programming is
not remembering exact words or syntax it
is
breaking down a problem working out how
to solve it and then fixing
all the inevitable bugs in your solution
it's about holding lots of complicated
connections in your head
not the exact magic words that you need
this one time
i still forget which order to put basic
stuff in sometimes
anyway the first line loads in the bits
of node that deal with reading and
writing files
and the next line loads the entire
dictionary into a single long string
called
words the next line converts that single
string into an array a long list of
smaller strings
based on where the new line characters
are and now
we have an array of all the words in the
english language basically
just a long list of strings let's see
how long that array is by telling the
console to output the array's length
okay more than 000 words each one a
separate item
in that array called words next problem
we need to filter that list
and remove any words that use letters
that we can't display with seven
segments which
gives us an interesting design problem
which letters
can't we display now i'm going to use
fancy graphics here rather than actual
seven segment displays but for extra
credit
you can try and figure out the after
effects expressions that i use to make
these
letters a through f are easy there's
almost a standard for those but
g is difficult we can't use the obvious
pattern because that's a six or a nine
if it's lower case
and if we use an alternate pattern for
it it's not really a g
it's a c with aspirations but be fair if
any of those patterns appear at the
start of a word like goal
no one's going to look at it and go oh
six oh but
i'm gonna make the call that we don't
allow it i think
i is all right though like that's
clearly an i it's not like the
half-assed g which sort of looked kind
of like a c
it's clear i mean i don't care that i'm
not applying straight rules here
i'm just going on what feels right and
if you disagree you can fix it in your
version
other letters that i'm ruling out k just
can't be done requires a diagonal
m i've seen displayed like this before
but no not having it n
is borderline but i'm going to allow it
because there's nothing else it could be
q is out that is just a nine r i will
allow if it's lower case
s is okay same reasons as i but there's
no way to do v
or w or x and as for z no it needs the
diagonals
not having it here's our alphabet then
18 letters left
eight disallowed it's actually more than
i'd expected left in there
i'm gonna cheat i know this is called
the basics but doing this the long way
would be really dull so i'm gonna put
those disallowed letters
into something called a regular
expression or a regex or
regex whichever those slashes indicate
that it's a regex and whatever's inside
those slashes
is like a test that a string can match
against
so this regex would match any word with
an x in it whether that x is start or
middle or end
as long as there's an x somewhere in the
string it passes that test
if we put all our disallowed letters in
then surround them with square brackets
so the treat is a class
this regex will match any string any
word with
any of those letters anywhere in it if a
string matches this
we cannot use it regular expressions are
a heck of a lot more complicated than
this and they can boggle
even experience programmers minds but
using one here
will save me about five minutes of
really dull script later on
the good news is we can now just use the
function match to test a string against
this regular expression which i'm
calling
bad letters and it'll tell us whether
there are any bad letters
in there so how do we filter
the array one of the important
trade-offs here is between code
that is fast and code that everyone can
understand
this is not going to be an efficient and
fast approach but because we're running
it on a modern pc
at the command line and we don't mind
waiting a fraction of a second after
telling it to go
it's no big deal it's more important
that i can show the code and explain it
and
look at it again later and understand it
but imagine if something like this had
to be run on the scale of youtube or
google running
millions or billions of times a day
every minor improvement
you could make would be worth it at some
point i should do a video about big
o notation but now is not the time here
where we're just writing code to find
the answer to one simple question
don't worry about it sure there are more
elegant solutions but
this is going to be easy to explain i'm
going to declare an
empty string longest acceptable word and
then i'm going to tell the code to start
testing every word in the array
this line will run the code in between
those brackets once for each word and on
each run through this variable
test word will be the next word in the
list
first question is the word we're looking
at shorter
or the same length as the current
longest acceptable word if it is
then we can just ignore it we know it's
not longer it's of no use to us and we
can just say
continue that continues skips the rest
of the loop kicks us back to the start
with the next word
some people hate continue they think it
shouldn't be used anywhere because it
can cause confusion
and yeah it can but i reckon for things
like this
it's fine anyway this will save a lot of
processing time because after the first
few words
we're not even gonna bother to analyze
the short ones we'll just
ignore them so let's say we've got to
this point in the code it's a new
longer possible word is it acceptable
here we can use our regular expression
from earlier does the word match our
test for bad letters if it does
it's not acceptable ignore it ignore the
rest of the loop
continue on to the next word in the list
but if it's past both of those tests if
we've got to this point
then we know our word is longer than
anything we've accepted before
and it has no bad letters in it so we
change the longest acceptable word to be
our new word
and we start over again with the next
one in the array and when we're done
longest acceptable word will be the
longest acceptable word
we tell the code to write that out and
the result is
ah that's that's actually the longest
word in the list anyway
you know what i am going to rule out i
and o they are just numbers with
aspirations
fortunately we have made the code easy
to edit so we can just make that change
[Music]
and
sure fine that'll that'll do the lesson
here i guess is that sometimes you might
write code to find something out and the
answer
is really unsatisfying of course there
is one thing we're missing here
our test was only checking for words
longer than the current acceptable one
what happens if there was another
acceptable word
of the same length we'd have ignored it
there could
be multiple correct answers but i'll
leave checking that
up to you thank you very much to the
center for computing history in
cambridge for lending me their space and
their megaprocessor
thank you also to all my proofreading
team who made sure i got the script
you